le coc vide a mis à genoux toute la
planète des pans entiers de l'économie
mais la petite entreprise de l'armement
ne connaît pas la crise alors que le
monde se confiner hiberner les marchands
de canons négocier leurs arsenaux
flambant neuf les plus grands groupes
d'armement ont enregistré des ventes
records en 2020 selon une étude de
l'institut international de recherche
sur la paix de stockholm
en effet les 100 plus grands fabricants
d'armes ont totalisé 531 milliards de
dollars soit 470 milliards d'euros alors
que l'économie mondiale chuté de 3,1
pour cent le secteur de l'armement
croise et de 1,3 pour cent il faut dire
que ce marché a été soutenu durant la
crise épidémique dans une grande partie
du monde les dépenses militaires ont
augmenté et certains gouvernements ou
même accélérer leur payement à
l'industrie de l'armement afin de
limiter l'impact de la crise de lakovic
19 qui figurent dans les dix premiers
marchands d'armes dans le monde six sont
américains il n'y a qu'une entreprise
européenne dans le top 10 un britannique
et trois groupes chinois y figurent les
compagnies chinoises du top 100 ont
vendu pour 66,8 milliards de dollars
d'armes en 2020 elle représente 13% des
ventes d'armes total du top 100 outre la
croissance de l'empiré du milieu dans le
secteur de l'armement une autre tendance
est à noter les grands groupes
américains acquiert de petites
entreprises prometteuses dans les
technologies spatiales augurant du futur
de la guerre le marché fut donc
florissant pour tous en 2020 pour les
groupes du top 100 à l'exception de la
russie qui a enregistré une perte de 6
points 5 % et de la france qui encaisse
-7 7% par ailleurs en 2020 la france a
réalisé des commandes pour un montant de
4,9 milliards d'euros contre 8,3
milliards d'euros en 2019 soit une
baisse de 41% selon le dernier rapport
parlementaire sur les exportations
d'armes qu'à cela ne tienne l'hexagone
compte bien revenir dans la course aux
étoiles avec une vente record celle de
80 avions de combat rafale aux émirats
arabes unis 16 milliards d'euros le plus
gros contrat d'armement jamais signé à
l'exportation la plus importante
commande jamais décroché par dassault
aviation il s'est établi dans le cadre
confortable d'un partenariat stratégique
entre la france et les émirats où on
écoute le porte parole désarmée
grandjean notre présence aux émirats
c'est aussi une vigie sur le sol indien
et ce partenariat est un élément clé de
notre stratégie indo pacifique
ce succès à l'exportation nous devons à
la force de nos liens stratégiques avec
les émirats à une équipe de france
soudée et bien sûr un avion d'exception
c'est 80 rafales seront livrés entre
2026 et 2031 une vente qui a suscité les
critiques de certains politiques comme
yannick jadot qui estime que la france
nous fait honte quand l arme des régimes
autoritaires qui méprise les droits
humains amnesty international a aussi
noté une nouvelle preuve que la france
continue d'ignorer ses engagements
internationaux au profit d'un
partenariat stratégique avec un pays
engagé au yémen mais gérard larcher le
président du sénat préfère le
pragmatisme la question des droits
humains existent mais si la france veut
demain souveraine elle doit continuer à
s'équiper d'armes d'excellence et à les
vendre dans le top 100 des priorités il
ya bien les droits humains mais ils ne
sont juste pas en tête du classement
nota bene